I'm curious mr. gökmen how exactly did
you amass such a detailed knowledge of
new Bordeaux like I tell any of you
[__] mr. Donavan look new Bordeaux
is more than an outline on a map its
collection of districts cultures people
[Music]
my job was to listen and observe
identify the relevant target provide
Lincoln with a blueprint he did the rest
could you give this committee an example
of what you mean yeah all right
take delray Hollow where Lincoln grew up
the hollows filled with pride hope up
beneath that is a layer of fear of anger
of a sense you got a scratch and claw
forever
Briscoe fields
manicured lawns perfect smiles southern
charm thing is it's all a show a facade
just because the knife comes out of a
monogrammed sleeve doesn't mean it won't
cut your throat mmm
French war home to every fantasy and
perversion you can imagine but if you're
not careful those appetites will come
back around and you be the very thing
that kills you by you phantom it's
beautiful down there Sarina it's also
vicious while unpredictable
ah yes pine fir done a proud people the
Irish the entire district runs on
whiskey and rage people up there never
back down never on the surface
southbounds looks like a nice
blue-collar neighborhood safe friendly
even it's all a cover though cover for
violence and lawlessness
you could almost mistake Barclay mills
and Tickfaw Harbor for normal American
industrial zones but in order to do that
you'd have to ignore all the brutality
and workplace accidents downtown the
prosperous heart of the city concrete
steel wheels of government and greasing
the whole thing is an endless stream of
graft and corruption
then there's River row hold dam
districts just one never-ending knife
fight this is all very poetic mr.
Donavan but it doesn't explain a Lincoln
clay took down the entire city in the
summer of 68 he did it by mastering the
one thing everyone in new Bordeaux
understands
[Applause]
power
[Music]
[Applause]